bonjour Patrice gomana j'ai 23 ans
j'habite sur la positionession j'ai le
pmib j'ai un petit garçon mon objectif
professionnel à moi c'est de devenir
responsable d'exploitation ou
responsable d'entrepôt en 2009 j'ai
obtenu mon bac stg spécialité mercatique
ensuite j'ai travailler un peu et je me
suis vite remis dans le chemin de
laformation parce que ça meit nulle part
donc j'ai entrepris de faire un tite de
vendeur conseil en magasin que j'ai
effectué en parallèle dans une chaîne de
restauration rapide et là j'aimerais
bien intégré un BTS Transport en
alternance mes qualités pour ce poste
sont le sourire je suis quelqu'un de
très sociable et je suis déterminé moi
ce qui me plaît dans ce poste c'est les
responsabilités lié au métier et la
stabilité j'espère avoir retenu votre
attention et j'espère que ma candidature
portera ses fruit
mer